back in the 90s there weren't many
comedians quite as big as Jeff Foxworthy
he is relatable humor about being a
regular guy from the south and dared him
to millions and so did his extremely
popular you might be a redneck jokes
my definition of redneck it is a
glorious absence of sophistication
Foxworthy's albums sold so well that he
became the most successful comedy
recording artist of all time he also
starred in his own Network sitcom hosted
are you smarter than a fifth grader and
headlined the Blue Collar Comedy Tour
with Bill Engvall Larry the Cable Guy
and Ron White's today Foxworthy isn't
the white-hot King of Comedy he once was
but he still got a huge following and
keeps it very busy here's what he's been
up to lately
becoming a salesman fans might not see
Foxworthy shows or stand-up specials
while flipping through the channels as
much as they used to but they still
catch a glimpse of him on TV since 2015
Foxworthy has been the face and voice of
the Golden Corral buffet chain he's also
made ads for Purina deer chow and the
iscope an iPhone attachment that allows
hunters to take videos of whatever they
see through their gunsights
most of these products fit into his
down-home aesthetic and he's also got
his own marketplace in play as well in
2011 he started his own sports equipment
company called Foxworthy outdoors the
company sells a wide array of gear
including Jeff Foxworthy beef jerky and
redneck themed t-shirts of course the
storefront is also an umbrella under
which Foxworthy produces a series inside
and out but he's not just in the
business of selling stuff these days
turning to philanthropy for a guy who's
positioned himself as such a
salt-of-the-earth type of person it's
only natural that he should put his
money where his mouth is
so Foxworthy has made good use of his
fame and fortune over the years by
investing in several charitable
endeavors it starts at home
as foxworthy outdoors helps fund hunting
trips on Foxworthy's land preserved for
wounded soldiers and children with
life-threatening illnesses Plus in 2012
he granted a local land trust a
conservation easement over 1,000 acres
of his property in Georgia to protect
the property from construction and for
more than a decade the comedian and his
family have worked with the humanitarian
aid organization called compassion
international even traveling to Rwanda
to help in and around the organization's
Development Center another cause
Foxworthy goes out of his way to support
is cure cha
hood cancer an organization based near
his home in Atlanta and for locals
around his hometown he's been known to
pick up the tab on a grocery bill when
things got tight to continuing his
career while it might seem like Jeff
Foxworthy has disappeared from the
spotlight he's still very busy logging
all those hours on the stage and on TV
made Foxworthy's voices recognizable as
his face and name so in recent years
he's lent his high-pitched drawl to a
bunch of animated projects including the
Smurfs hatched Ozzy and Bunyan and babe
be smurfed and in 2013 CMT aired 13
episodes of bounty hunters an animated
sitcom about a small-town bail bonds
business starring Foxworthy alongside
his old Blue Collar Comedy Tour mates
Plus after hosting are you smarter than
a 5th grader for five seasons Jeff
Foxworthy continued to frequent the
reality competition circuit as well he
appeared in two episodes of ABC's Shark
Tank and headlined the American
adaptation of Britain's the Great
British Bake Off for a single season at
CBS
he's also hosted the American Bible
Challenge which tested people's
familiarity with the titular book
meanwhile his stand-up career is still
ticking along strong to Foxworthy
continues to tour the nation with his
signature phrases playing a number of
dates each year at fairs comedy clubs
and casinos and in 2017
he co-headlined Jeff and Larry's
backyard barbeque tour would Larry the
Cable Guy the pair also teamed up to
make a special for Netflix called we've
been thinking wherein he announced that
he might have a new career path
altogether in mind well I haven't
decided if I'm running for president or
not yet in other words we haven't heard
the last of Jeff Foxworthy just yet
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
let's check out all this cool stuff we
know you love to
[Music]